remember different let's go is what
makes you spider-man
my name is Danny Demian I'm the visual
effects supervisor and I'm Joshua
beverage I was head of character
animation on spider-man into the spider
verse my name is Peter Parker I'm pretty
sure you know the rest when we started
the film we really didn't know what we
wanted the film to look like we did know
what our inspiration was we all loved
comic books and we went back and we
looked at a comic books to see what was
special about them we fell in love with
the halftone 2 hatching and the line
work we were really inspired by Jack
Kirby's illustrations he has the kirby
crackle or kirby dots that he uses a lot
you'll see man Johnson's motif through
the entire movie and a lot of the
techniques or visuals that came from how
the comic books were printed we wanted
to stay away from anything that was soft
or did not look like it belongs in the
illustrated world that included motion
blur that includes the camera focus so
one of the great things about this movie
because it all feels like it's printed
in community could stop on absolutely
every frame and it's all clear you can
understand where it's coming from and
going to it looks like an illustration
on every frozen frame this very first
shot of miles I love because we got to
do this one at the very very end of the
movie we did that one specifically so
late because the song was being written
of while we were making it so we
actually started animating before the
song he's seeing to was finished
[Music]
motif wise the goal for this this scene
is seen is to make me feel as like in
his element as possible but he's in his
neighborhood he loved this place and
he's comfortable there it's a very
inviting place so the palette the
lighting it's a comfortable safe space
and this is this starts to get
contrasted as we go to the school where
the lighting starts to get a little
harsher and we we kind of leave some of
the comfort of of his environment New
York is an iconic part of the movie yeah
and we'd really drilled into trying to
treat New York the way only animation
can treat it like it's a character and
not just the whole city of New York but
the borough's itself we treated like
different characters Manhattan was this
exaggeration of scale and license
brightness the shot where our miles is
leaping off the building I thought it is
miles
a leap of faith it has an illustrated
feel to it and it starts with these
models stood on their own kind of look
broken all the buildings are portions
that don't make sense for a New York and
there's cute in a way deliver miles they
were yeah you have buildings that were
maybe eight to ten times taller than
they should be for our new yorking shots
they're also weirdly compulsive it's
when you see it from the shot camera it
all looks really I mean it looks really
cool you pull from the side and you view
it through a witness camera you can see
that not only are the building very
strange proportions but the layout is
really messed up it's it's really weird
broken looking but from the camera it's
it's an amazingly powerful shot what
you're seeing here is a test environment
some people might look at the Train some
people might look at miles you're seeing
the color shift in and out of
registration the way that the colors
might be misprinted if they weren't
lined up properly so it definitely puts
one area in focus but the same time it
still avoids that that lens feel or the
softness
so this sequences we called sitting back
there it's really the first time we see
Myles and his dad really interacting in
the movie that first shot of this run
where they're rounding the corner in
front of that TV screen is a great
example of offsetting the characters in
the foreground so you can pay attention
to the screen in focus
this one test shot one of the key things
we really discovered from it was how
much we could deconstruct level of
detail at a distance if you look really
closely all of the traffic in this image
behind that one passing lane is all just
simple color blobs and the simple color
blobs represent a full city and it was a
great aha moment for the entire team
that we were going to populate it with a
thousand cars and full of every single
light in there we took that idea and we
applied it to a lot in the movie
including every interior and it's a
great example of handling level of
detail in a way we hadn't traditionally
I didn't have to have the team animate
hundreds and hundreds of cars and
characters and write populate every
building with people and just get that
reduced later it was color blob and then
we were looking for opportunities to
make things simpler in animation all
throughout the movie sometimes like even
we'd have characters holding flashlights
and if you didn't see them we didn't
animate them
that concept became an that starting
ground for another test if you notice
really closely on the bus that's
crossing the scene it's actually just a
deconstructed painting there's not forty
characters all sitting within that bus
we're also introducing pop frames in it
where it's just hand-drawn and it's it's
really simple and it could be basically
it's taken out of a simple comic we're
starting to realize that we have an
opportunity here to create a new visual
language line work is one of those
things we had to solve a lot of
different ways it's amazing how much one
little line for a furrow or a dimple can
make you feel completely different about
the expression form lines describe the
shape of something I think like a nose
the effects team did this amazing thing
where we had the character designer make
a library of drawings so that was
something we could make rules for this
is the way that nose would look from
this head angle to camera and we made it
a whole bunch of poses that defined that
an effects team would recreate those in
3d space with those rules of head angle
to camera and then let the machine
learning program try and guess where
those drawings would go and a person
would correct it every time it was wrong
making it therefore another rule and
little by little we're teaching the
computer to make drawings that we find
redundant so like a example like where
miles is scrunching is faced right there
usually the characters like this you'd
have to be wrinkling the model in order
to get this sort of creasing I would
never be as satisfying as a simple
stroke you can just have the stroke on
top of it and it's far more expressive
and we understand it it's more clear all
that technology was in the service of
allowing artists more freedom to do
things by hand and it all all became a
part of this hand crafted feel
how the saying goes early on we realized
that animating on twos was gonna be a
great solution for a couple of reasons
if you just watch it at speed your ears
immersed in the movie you're not
noticing all these things are really
sneakily hidden in there but if you
pause and flow down the same footage and
you'll see only every other frame while
this animated that's what we're
describing as on twos you get that nice
crispness that pop art feel we're
looking for almost every shot in the
movie the cameras are on once so we had
to come up with all kinds of different
technical solutions for how to make our
performances with our characters on to
work with different styles of camera
always on ones so if we just look at one
scene for the movie this one of miles
running through the forest you can see
he's going in and out of sync with the
camera if the camera is moving at high
speed through this handheld ones through
an entire forest but Peter and miles
they're both usually animated on twos
but we're going in and out of sync with
them just so you're getting that sort of
feeling of they're not quite on the same
page the real goal of this section is to
make miles feel like he's getting it
miles is not quite in his element he
hasn't learned to be a hero yet he
hasn't figured out how to well in
web-swing he starts really out of sync
with Peter Peter being in his and his
mastery and at this being his comfort
zone isn't a big deal for him so the
beautiful thing about this sequence is
we're literally seeing the two of them
get on the same page they start more out
of sync and little by little get into
sync with each other and they're even on
different frame rates until they both
get it together and because it's on Tues
we'd clarify that sort of posing and
flipping Peter doing the iconic low
center of gravity Spidey poses and miles
little by little gets to get there by
the end of it and then you see them make
eye contact and bond over that
experience and then you can see Peter
glitch here he's not supposed to be in
this spider-verse and so all the all the
superheroes that come to this
spider-verse from theirs they struggle
with this dimensional glitching hey guys
okay who are you i'm gwen stacy so we
had to bring in each of the spider
people from different universes and
making this different as possible while
still standing next to each other and
looking like they looked good next to
each other there was the perfect
handsome Spidey the goal with him was
how perfect of a hero could we make him
the hood was gonna be a great role model
for miles and then take him away and
we'll replace him with Peter be Parker
or burrito Peter this is your universe
soggy it's weird it's gross he's no
longer in his prime because maybe she'd
be retired by now it's one of the few
more fights he's lost a lot more fights
he he's a reluctant man sorry you have
money right I'm not very liquid right
now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher
there's Gwen Stacy actually Gwen Stacy
is of all of the spider people the hero
prime she is the most capable and adept
and in charge but she's also probably
had the most recent trauma so she has a
little bit more than
fighter noir hey fellas he looks black
and white even in our world he never
does get any collar he has the best
one-liners wherever I go the wind
follows the wind smells like rain
penny Parker Annie Parker was the only
spider person that doesn't have
superpowers of her own and she is has a
mental telekinetic relationship with the
spider that runs her robot named SPDR
that her father created spider-ham wacky
spider-man
yeah he's the most - we were trying to
be you know cartoonists that I could
merely trying to make him feel as
hand-wrought as possible he's got a
giant hammer that he pulled in his
pocket yep my name is Peter Parker
characters like miles Peter and Gwen
they all came from the same physical
universe we're like the laws of reality
or all somewhat similar and more extreme
characters like ham and war and
especially penny Parker we got to push
them back how differently could we make
them the final battle the wheels fall
off we've turned everything to 11
everything is going nuts so we have this
abstract world kind of inspired by Kirby
dots the Kirby dots are not just an
aesthetic thing their nod to the
collider beam which which is a particle
beam and depending on what's happening
in which characters are important the
palette is shifting based on the colors
and the worlds of or the spider-verse
colors of those characters
and then when when you get to the most
emotional part where it's just miles in
and kingpin and you know this is this is
the final moments of the final battle we
lose all color it's black the Kirby dots
are now just volumes of nothing them
yeah enveloping them and it becomes
really just about them and it also sets
up incredibly beautifully the contrast
of when miles finally uses his super
power with the touch
[Applause]
you've now established this black
background for this beautiful strike of
his
[Music]
this was a special project there's not
very many times where you really get to
do something new it had to be bold it
had to be different and I was Adam and
the audience put on us before we even
started really everybody held hands from
the very beginning to try to do
something special and to try to push
animation somewhere where or hadn't been
different
[Music]